it's funny because i had a friend say
this to me that
because i kept going through stuff and
she was like tiffany you know whatever
it is that your soul needs to learn in
this moment you're revisiting this for a
reason
you know and that that reason may not
have anything to do with you
and it may be a story that you're going
to tell so i'm actually starting to get
toward that
where because because you really when
you're going through things you're like
what is the point of this and maybe that
is the point the point to kind of see
yourself in the other and this
you know collective consciousness that
you know and
to get beyond that this life is just
about me right here and right now that
something i could do
might be just the the tip of the iceberg
that's going to have
impacts for years and decades to come
when i'm or generations to come when i'm
long gone and not remember but that's
still a legacy
right like maybe that's the point to get
us away from this ego driven
move in the world so african-american
language though
is very much prominent in the discipline
especially in sociolinguistics
um but for anthropology
i did not see that being explored as
much and
i come from a background where i was
looking at
a part of african american language
which is called african american
vernacular english
which people when they think of that
they think of bionics but that term is
very loaded and problematic
and it has negative connotations because
of how it was portrayed
in the 90s but i look at it and there's
all these verbal art traditions
like hip-hop um black sermonizing from
black preachers
signifying all these other things these
traditions that
impact larger american culture and i
want to look at it from a positive
perspective
and i'm thinking these verbal art
traditions the way to do it it's
artistic it's creative it's innovative
but it's being taken up outside of the
african-american community in very
interesting ways
consciously or unconsciously that is
having long-term
influence on the culture and should be
recognized and that i hadn't seen that
much
in linguistic anthropology as i wanted
personally so i felt speaking of a
calling and a gift and
i felt a responsibility of something
larger than me
needs to do this so that african
americans behind me can come
and have these conversations we can
anthropologists can then
look um at the communities that they're
ignoring
i just say conscious or unconscious and
say hmm
we need to have more conversations
around this so
that's what i'm trying to do someone's
opinion may contradict yours
where's my friend alan it's all about
your perspective
who are we and what is the nature of
this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
i'm your host
alan sakyon we are on site at the
american anthropological association's
annual meeting
in vancouver british columbia for our
second partnership with them
we are now going to be talking about
linguistic anthropology and so much more
we have tiffany marquis jones joining us
on the show hello
hi t what's up what's up coming on thank
you for having me
i'm very pumped for our conversations
this is gonna be a lot of fun
i wanna start things off with some of
our big picture questions we like asking
our guests
fair enough are we really all one
now our linguistic anthropologist
so words matter yes when you say
we who is we
or should i define that yeah this is
this is good point
if i was to define we i would say
all that is how would you define the we
in that question okay i'll try to so
it's interesting because when i think of
we
and because we're sitting in the
building of the triple a conference
we could be we as anthropologists
we now i would think just because i am
american
we're talking about america but we're
sitting in canada so i assume a global
context we as in people
but then i also am aware that we could
be in connection to nature and to
animals into so
i have multiple levels of wii and i have
something to say about all of that
okay oh you want to go at each level i
can oh my goodness
okay breaking down how you want to break
it down okay
good if i'm talking specifically about
anthropology i think the
um the polished answer was
yes we are all a discipline of one but i
think something that has been very much
discussed here is how it's
very splintered like everyone sits in
their silos we have four fields
linguistic anthropology bioanthropology
archaeology and then the cultural aspect
now i studied linguistic anthropology
and
we i feel very siloed i feel like i
don't experience the other fields as
much and also i'm a black anthropologist
i don't feel like i experience other
black anthropologists as much as i would
like to and there's an association of
black anthropology so i feel very
separated out and also i'm always the
only
linguistic anthropologist in the room i
get questioned whether i am doing
anthropology when i am doing linguistics
so it's just very fascinating so i don't
think i feel that especially as a
graduate student
which is interesting because i do cross
over and do other aspects and a lot of
other
fields feed into my work but they're so
specialized i think people like to keep
their little boundary of i am a
biological
anthropologist or physical
anthropologist i am a linguistic
anthropology specific because that's
going to determine where you get jobs
who
values your work who what kind of
conversations you can participate in
america if i'm going to go up the ladder
i'm a black woman african-american
scholar
who's studying gentrification in
washington d.c
where people's cultures are being
railroaded and
kicked out because of the transplants
that are moving in
and they're being silenced and ignored
so we very much
feels like it does not cover
african-american culture
weed depends on dominance a lot of times
you know
places or talks of whiteness in
particular or through the lens of
whiteness i should say
so sometimes when people are in a room
and it's um mixed and especially if i'm
the only woman of color and people say
we
i'm very much i'm quick to jump in and
say that doesn't represent my experience
that doesn't represent how i would
approach this so no i very much don't
feel like
my culture and community is always a
part of that we
globally
someone has said that racism is now
being replaced with tribalism
from a national perspective and very
much
the americas is or i would say america
the states
has ostracized itself from a lot of
people right now right
so i don't know if we fit in the same or
see ourselves in the global community as
much as i would like i see myself as a
global citizen
because we are the world not sure
anymore
especially in this current context but i
like to believe
that we are all apart
and affected and influenced by one
another where i'm here
in the states in urban culture versus
someone on the other side of the room
um versus someone on the other side of
the world i do feel like
what i do over here can't what's what's
that phrase like a ripple over here will
create like that butterfly flat i do
believe that there's this
constant flow of energy that happens
spiritually
emotionally mentally i do feel like we
are all connected whether or not we
realize and act from that position
not so much but i believe we're
connected spiritually to animals to
nature
to divine all of it yes
sorry wrong answer yes i i
i really appreciated your breakdown a
lot
and i want to hit the ball back on
the last point because we'll get to that
um to your the middle point that you
made especially when we
get deeper into your research um and uh
and i know i'm confident that triple a
will over time
become even more um cohesive across
those four that you initially mentioned
i hope so the first part i'm very
confident
um it's already so beautifully
multi-disciplinary
um in the very last part
on a spiritual level
on a deep interconnected level of
all is the most upstream
issue that our society faces
that is causing all of the downstream
symptoms that we see
the fact that we ourselves are not
deeply immersed in that
interconnectedness
that we are not deeply immersed in
unconditional love
and that we are not
passionate about having when every child
comes into the world them to
experientially experience
i do see that um
so i actually had an interesting
conversation with a friend
um about particularly i think the black
experience is very much rooted in
weakness
whether we want it to or not if you know
if i see someone on the news that has
done something great in their
african-american descent i'm we're all
like yes that's a win
if i see someone that has you know
committed a crime and it's
then judges all black people it's like
oh my gosh what happened to us
it's weakness right so then i move in
that sense of
what i'm doing is going to impact my
community i don't think that bleeds out
and this person has said
that they've talked to people that say
you know coming from a european
tradition i don't really think of that
weakness from my community that way
unless it's just their family or blood
ties or things of that nature
so as someone who kind of partially
moves in weakness in that sense
i do think the world is lacking that
seeing themselves in other cultures and
other people
seeing themselves even in how we treat
animals how we treat the environment how
we relate to spaces is very much like
well
you know that's not going to bother me
over there you know if
if i'm doing this if it doesn't impact
my immediate environment
it's fine right i don't see what's going
to happen over there so why should i
care or
if it um impacts this economy or the
globe
50 years from now if the world blows up
well i'm dead i don't care we don't see
ourselves in even the generations behind
us
so i do think that is a problem and part
of why some of the issues that we're
experiencing
we don't know how to deal with it
because we're kind of disassociating
that spiritual emotional
mental phys all these connections these
points of connections whether it's
racism whether it's sexism right because
if it's
on gender dynamics well i don't i can't
identify with that
if it's race dynamics i can't i did
social economics all of this
right and we start from this
self-experience if i don't get it i
can't empathize with it if i didn't go
through that
how do i know how to talk about that so
and it takes a specific kind of person's
willing to
see themselves in a global community or
a interconnected
way to kind of say let me if i don't
understand it figure out
how i am impacting other spaces and
other places
that makes sense yeah and
some of the most i guess indigenous
wisdom around things like a seventh
generation principle
you've got to think that far out in
advance about all of the different
decisions that you make or that the
breath of air that i take in comes from
phytoplankton and trees the bite of food
comes from the power of the sun
these are just things that if a child is
born in a metropolis and they don't
get to see the cosmos because of light
pollution and they exchange a sheet of
paper for the apple
that it's inevitable that there's going
to be a sense of disconnection
right and stacked up on top of boxes now
having to go out to
trees and beaches for nature therapy i
mean it's getting quite ridiculous
to you know to juxtapose these two
indigenating modernity
and then try and see if maybe actually
the marriage of the two
can actually build that best forward
path
right right and it's interesting
recently i was teaching a class of
kindergarteners and just on something
really small and it really helped me
understand this
about this connectedness they get in a
lot of food in this
class through this program and they
wouldn't eat it they would just waste it
play with it throw it away
and i was getting really disturbed by
that because i'm just thinking how many
homeless did we walk over that could
have eaten that food you know or how
many things wasn't
properly ciphered into uh recycling bins
that could help this planet and
so i started to say okay i understand
you're kindergartner i understand your
preschool let's start to have these
conversations about how
what you do in this moment with this
plate with this food can impact so many
people or down the road and so we
started talking i made that into a
lesson about
recycling about responsibility okay if
you don't want the food don't touch it
because then we can then use it to give
it to
the homeless or shelters or whatever
things like that and it was really
interesting they
they can't even start to fathom that
what i do will impact someone i've never
seen
or a world that i might not understand
or interact with or that if i
put this in this right bin it could be
recycled and reused for another person
right and it was really interesting to
see that from a child's eyes
that if you can have these conversations
from very young
right i think that then you get
socialized into that weakness into this
us and the world and how what i do
impacts
other things but if we don't what does
that responsibility
look like 20 years from now when that
kindergartner's older
right so i yeah i do think it's very
fascinating
and because i'm constantly judging
myself from this weakness i'm also aware
that
the work that i'm doing right now is
gonna help her not help someone
20 15 20 years from now so
it's but i am aware of that that's not
always been because
i wanted to think that way it's because
i'm aware that people who did not think
about me years before
i'm still trying to break through those
barriers and those boundaries if that
makes sense
so i think it if you're impacted in a
way that you re
recognize that other people's actions
have hurt me hopefully it will help you
locate yourself that
the same going backwards and in terms of
indigeneity and modernity and things of
that nature
we are because we're so siloed and we
like to think things in
static terms if we only understand
indigenous being past
or rule or other or
and whatever these romanticized notions
and we don't see
how indigeneity is reflected today if i
don't encounter other cultures that are
repping indigenous
um perspectives and not the way that i
see it
because right if someone says well this
is how i understand ingenity
and then someone's indigenous like well
actually but if you don't give them the
space to correct you or to reflect like
in contemporary terms it challenges your
norms
right then we're stuck i hope that makes
sense because i feel like i'm rambling
no you good okay totally i'm feeling i'm
feeling like this is
excellent there's there's another aspect
to this that you know you begin
uh showing us the sheer complexity of
of basically people not feeling we or
us or the one or unity god creation
source
big bang universe don't care what word
to use to describe it
that right there having this big
challenge for us
to kind of be like wait we are that
for us to remember that do you think
that's the whole purpose of this reality
reality as being what we're doing
on the earth reality as in this this
entire
experience of all that is
has created this for the exact purpose
of us trying to
realize that this is a big grand
challenge that we have to get through
that's so it's funny because i had a
friend say this to me that
because i kept going through stuff and
she was like tiffany you know whatever
it is that your soul needs to learn in
this moment you're revisiting this for a
reason
you know and that that reason may not
have anything to do with you
and it may be a story that you're gonna
tell so i'm actually starting to get
toward that
where because because you really when
you're going through things you're like
what is the point
of this and maybe that is the point the
point to kind of see yourself in the
other and this
you know collective consciousness that
you know and
to get beyond that this life is just
about me right here and right now that
something i could do
might be just the the tip of the iceberg
that's going to have
impacts for years and decades to come
when i'm or generations to come when i'm
long gone and not remember but that's
still a legacy you're right like
maybe that's the point to get us away
from this ego driven
yeah move in the world yeah yes
yes you're viewing yourself more
like a divine being that is a
that has a role to figure out in this
big
let's say experience that we're all a
part of and if you view
something that is an obstacle as
something that is a challenge to
overcome
and to level up gain experience points
become better help
the world flourish be in service find
your gifts bring them forth
that sort of a viewpoint on this can
just help drive people towards um
things that transcend them individually
their ego
and things that bring us more to an ego
less
selfless prosperous right place
and so that is something that we
obsessively talk about on the program
i'm glad that we had that back and forth
on it let's get into
let's get into the depth on linguistic
anthropology um
study of african american language and
its verbal art
traditions sounds like a mouthful right
yes
this is a complex um this is very
complex in the first place because
we from what we know this was what about
how many 500-ish years ago even be the
beginnings
of an african american something that's
right
yeah and it's whatever african-american
language is is still becoming known
it's still being figured out like the
term african-american language has just
shifted from african-american english
not that long ago
and before that black english and before
the africa
you know language and before that other
so it's been iterations of this evolving
because even the study of
african-american language was done from
a white point of view of men trying
to figure out what is this babel talk as
they put it or this broken english or
this bad talk that slaves are doing
up until the point where then black
scholars start to well and i would say
some white scholars start to show like
no this is a structured language that
has its rules
and it is not incorrect it is not
inferior to that standard american
english is one variety
and then there's this other language
variety that is not less than
is just for this community and then
black scholars took that over and
and started to do excellent work and
showing like it's not even just
one level black it's middle class black
it's black in
urban spaces it's black and queer it's
it's female
african american women's language so
it's still very much evolving
today and and and then the roles that i
take with it
as just a phd student i'm sure i'm only
getting like a pin prick of
the large review for the people who've
been in this field for a while and see
it involved
evolve in front of their eyes i will i
i'm sure completely different experience
of that so african-american language
though
is very much prominent in the discipline
especially in sociolinguistics
but for anthropology i did not see that
being explored as much and i come from a
background where i was looking at
a part of african american language
which is called african american
vernacular english
which people when they think of that
they think of bionics but that term is
very loaded and problematic
and it has negative connotations because
of how it was portrayed
in the 90s but i look at it and there's
all these verbal art traditions like
hip-hop black sermonizing from black
preachers
signifying all these other things these
traditions that
impact larger american culture and i
want to look at it from a positive
perspective
and i'm thinking these verbal art
traditions the way to do it it's
artistic it's creative it's innovative
but it's being taken up outside of the
african-american community in very
interesting ways
consciously or unconsciously that is
having long-term
influence on the culture and should be
recognized and that i hadn't seen that
much
in linguistic anthropology as i wanted
personally so i felt speaking of a
calling and a gift and
i felt a responsibility of something
larger than me needs
to do this so that african americans
behind me can come
and have these conversations we can
anthropologists can then
look um at the communities that they're
ignoring
i just say conscious or unconscious and
say hmm
we need to have more conversations
around this so
that's what i'm trying to do wow
even just that breakdown of like what
from 500 years
of what uh has unfolded has then
broken down into so many other
subcategories of linguistic anthropology
is that in itself is already whoa and
then after that
is well then you also had have
sociolinguistics
so it's like people have different
socioeconomic statuses
oh definitely i mean no
culture group community is a monolith
right there's so many levels to this
and i think the way black culture
sometimes or any you know
minority culture gets depicted as one
level but yeah
sociolinguists and linguistic
anthropologists and i won't go into
how they're very different but had to
bring in the socio-economic aspect of it
because i'm middle class black i grew up
in
the the second richest black county in
the nation which is in atlanta
i'm now studying a population that's in
the richest black county which is in d.c
pg county and so it became
very obvious that when we're talking
about african american english we
weren't necessarily always talking
people were thinking about in terms of
like low-income
urban spaces not even thinking about
regional varieties of african american
english what i'm going to see in new
york is going to be different in the
south
it's going to be different on the west
coast it's going to be different
depending on socioeconomics it's going
to be different depending on if i
align more prominently with black
culture if i'm moving in spaces where
i'm predominantly in white
areas how much i can code switch or if
i'm just participating in
other communities of culture whether
that's being i don't know blurred them
right the blurred
culture or whatever movements that
um for instance i'm in a belly dance
world
right like i might i might have other
kinds of varieties or other kinds of
jargon that would be specific so
everyone was just trying to be
as open and diverse as they were trying
to define african-american english so
they weren't
outsiding anyone and that led into
african-american women's language and
other
these pockets of the variety that are
still being unfolded
um and someone can pick up something in
five minutes
i mean five years from now and come up
with a new
definition or community that i might not
even be aware of so it's still very much
evolving
and this also includes america's
at-large like central and south america
well well when i say al definitely i'm
dealing with
african america in the states but there
is definitely
look at language in south america
there's definitely look at black
people in europe there's so many um
like i just left a discourse analysis
seminar with jennifer roth gordon looks
at afro-brazilians and race and talk
there
and that's going to be and realize a
little bit differently than african
americans just because of the
um the cultural perspective the way the
the national perspective is looked at
you know race gets talked about very
differently in the americas than it does
say in south america or in the caribbean
or in
africa like it's just going to look
different but when i'm saying aal i'm
really
literally looking at the
african-american experience yes
in the states in the united states so
give us give us an understanding of what
are
some of these findings around linguistic
anthropology
as well as um even to the
to the extent of some of the most
interesting aspects of these pockets
and also what are some of the obstacles
that are in the way
and how can we how can we build a social
fabric that enables
it to get rid of the obstacles make it
easier for people to actualize those
those gifts moving forward and when you
say obstacles actualizing gifts can you
just
yeah like anything that is um
some sort of an impediment to people
actualizing gifts so whether it be
yes yeah in my field yeah yeah
okay so because we just had randy on the
show and he was giving us
uh like he would walk up to his um
teacher in middle school and he would
start speaking and she would be like
where did you learn to speak like that
sorry that that that just gives me a
reaction
yeah well me too i'm just thinking like
well can we
make it so that we don't see like that
you know yeah yeah
i i wish i had this very pretty answer
for that can we make it so
that there's not these pockets that get
judged in certain ways or that there's
these open
access to explore language in all its
facets without it being
impeded it it's different i can only
talk about from my experience
and i had a lot of barriers to get to
the point where i could do this research
some would again conscious or
unconscious that could be argued
a lot of it has to do with just how
academia is in itself
in that it's been just driven from
dominant culture
and um so the
ways things get talked about as
especially as an african-american
scholar if i want to be able to
knock down doors i am very much aware
that i also
how is that gonna position me later if i
want jobs
to have certain conversations to move in
this space where people don't
peg me as a troublemaker right so if i'm
saying something that's challenging the
way people
already understand it and said oh no no
no we already got this figured out
thank you for your input but but you're
good you you young scholar thanks thank
you that's cute
um i don't know how to
sometimes infiltrate that right other
than to
it's for me a sheer will of being like
no i'm not going to deal with this and i
don't want people behind me dealing with
this and just
knocking down the doors and sometimes
that builds relationships and sometimes
that breaks relationships i've
had experiences of that where that's put
me in the place where
my work was blocked
in certain areas and in certain fields
and i had to kind of just be willing to
keep
being creative and move like water
through these crevices and find a way
out
so i think it's funny within
african-american language studies
a lot of the white scholars who were
doing research i was
listening to a documentary and they were
saying you know what it's time that
white skulls get out the way
and let black people talk about their
own language and i think that's a lot
that was that has to happen
people have to let the people who have
lived these experiences
who have the investment in these
communities and in this language
structures
be the experts in that and be willing to
again take an ego out of it and get out
of the way
and that's very hard when you've built a
career on being an a let's say an
african-american scholar as a non-black
person
or a you know i am a feminist but i am
male
whatever that is and you know getting
out of the way
so there's one in that sense of people
being willing to get
over themselves a little bit and just
say there's room at the table for
multiple perspectives and i might not
have the lock on that
but then there's also being willing
to go up against challenges where you're
someone that's
when you're doing this work recognizing
it's not easy it hasn't been easy for
those before us
and but i have a responsibility for
those behind me to keep trying
and as we talk about it more that will
create space for more talk
as we break down more walls that will
create more openness
and as i make good on this opportunity
that will create more opportunities
so it's very much from the top down the
power structures and then people being
responsible for like i want to be an
advocate in this way
i want to create opportunities in this
way it's both in
yeah speaking of people getting out of
the way we talk about this so much
on the show that we have in many ways
archaic codes that still govern
a world where very young consciousness
is trying to become
more sustainable is trying to evolve and
grow and heal
our planet to the next world and we have
just this grasp of in many ways greed
corruption just a bunch of old codes
that need to die
it's like let go of the throat of the
biosphere and
let the next evolution happen but they
don't want to let go because there's
money involved
in the old codes and so that's this
seems like a very similar uh way of
viewing that first one
and then on the second one and can i
just say yeah yeah go ahead
um and it's not even just money
sometimes it's just the comfort
right like i already am comfortable in
this way i don't want to give that up
because to be out of your comfort zone
is to lose power in itself
and then we're seeing that just to kind
of give it a language spin
we're seeing language and evolve right
before us when it comes to safe use of
pronouns
right but now we got an old system our
case system
why should i have to do that why should
i have to learn your pronoun that's not
how it's been for me
it's been he or she and it's by sex but
we're in now this movement where again
young
consciousness new right is evolving in
front of our eyes and saying no there's
non-gender binaries right i mean there's
non-binary gender
identity um there is or this new way of
understanding sexuality right there's
new pronouns that need to be
it's not and you can ask me what my
pronoun is and i and honor that
but what happens when people are like
nope that's uncomfortable for me i don't
want to do that i don't want to learn a
new system
because that's going to make me subject
to your expertise in this field or your
demands in this field
but the world has been bent to my will
for the longest time
getting out of the way involves that as
well being willing to be the novice in a
new area
that's evolving right before you this is
such an
interesting back and forth on what
uh in many ways is the very classical
um like open consciousness
trying to advance and evolve and then
somewhat of a more archaic consciousness
that's trying to
uh hit the ball back to the young one
saying well think about it this way
maybe it's better in this regard and
then it just goes back always
gatekeepers
well it's interesting to see that back
and forth because maybe there are
actually some times when
the uh maybe when the younger
consciousness is trying to make a move
in a certain direction
that there is a ball that's hit a back
uh from the older one consciousness that
says well
what about this that that that and then
the younger one goes well actually
you know this and that one are really
good and then yeah there's always this
it's a it's a joint it's co-constructed
it's not
one or the other because we also got to
honor our elders as well
because there's that memory and
consciousness that comes from the
tradition that
that has implications and should not
just be tossed out and or
not of newness either yes yes this is
well said and then the second part that
you mentioned i think so so interesting
is that when you have something like a
an analysis of of of
of of language that is being used
especially over
the use of african-american language
here in the last 500 years
i'm really curious as to what exactly
have been
um some of the most interesting ways of
perceiving how people have been
overcoming like you said
making it getting through obstacles
bringing gifts to the world
you were talking about like there are
you know we don't know
there's a they're the richest uh
african-american communities in dc
second which is in atlanta what is going
on in those
areas that is special about the way that
people are
talking or behaving that enables them to
be so wildly successful and how can
other people potentially take on
some of those habits so i'll speak more
about dc because that's where my
research is even though i'm from atlanta
i left and has been kind of more
ingrained in the dc culture
for i would say this decade and
with in consideration of
african-american language what drew me
in terms of gifts was to the spoken word
community there
spoken word poetry um to be specific um
and it's a perform for those who don't
know it's a performance poetry
um people kind of know it as you know
when they make fun of it they're like oh
snap snap and it's very much like
it's musical in nature as its own pacing
and and um it draws a lot from
african-american
culture in the sense that it's not just
someone reading a poem it's very
interactive it's almost like this
conversation the audience
talks back which brings in black church
traditions of this
call and response it brings in levels of
hip-hop culture
and what is so
good about this community and i want to
i don't want to own it like i'm
discovering this art by any means
because it's been here for a long time
and i am not the expert but they let me
into this world
but as a first as a fan i observed this
tradition in these open mic um spaces
where these artists and because that's
what they are
would use and i don't think they were
just saying like i'm using black
language i think they were speaking how
they would speaker in any way that they
felt was creative using interesting
metaphor
interesting pacing and rhyming in a way
that worked for them
but i'm seeing these black artists who
were pushing back at power structures
who were positioning
blackness as this thing to be proud of
was positioning black language in very
creative ways that
was you just can't walk on this or walk
into this stuff
it is a craft the way they make use of
words
but also the way they make use of being
a global citizen
you know it's using language to make it
a better place whether that is to
educate
um the masses on how
let's just say in dc let's go very
specific where gentrification
for instance is taking over where
african americans
that have been born and bred or located
in this area for a long time
their culture is kind of being erased as
white people
um the gentry the elites transplants
not all white but non-dc based are
moving in and taking over
they use their language kind of show let
me just show you what chocolate city is
let me show you what dc
is let me show you don't own these
spaces let me show you what you're
erasing let me bring in
and add in my flavor of language talk
about the food culture
talk about the history of dc defining
what chocolate city is to first educate
you
so that you're aware what you're erasing
consciously or unconsciously
but also to empower those who are from
these areas to say you know what you are
of importance you do have a space you do
have a place your story deserves to be
told
and the way spoken word is by giving a
person a mic and a stage in a moment
is very empowering in itself right so
when i saw
that that very much inspired me
maybe not to be a spoken word artist but
to use my voice
as an academic and of course i use my
voice as an academic to highlight them
but like to be empowered to talk about
black language
from a positive perspective to own it to
love it
but also i want to think about how i
want to be an artist in other ways like
it just empowered me to embrace myself
to embrace my dreams
that these groups of people who may not
have had every advantage and opportunity
and resources
are finding ways to literally we've been
doing this as black people making a
dollar out of 15
you know or making something out of
nothing turning a mayonnaise sandwich
into a meal like they
use what they have naturally and
language
and and what they love in terms of
culture and music and poetry
and that blend and create
this beautiful art form right
that is reflective of who they are who
they want to be
and informing other people how they can
more responsibly move about in the world
so they might challenge hyper or toxic
masculinity
they might challenge systems of abuse
whether that's physical emotional or
whatever or they might even challenge
getting involved
in your voting process they use it for
whatever platforms
right to talk about love even it's not
just from social advocacy in that way to
say black love is beautiful family is
beautiful
so i love that it challenges me every
time i go in these spaces
um and to do it in an artistic way makes
it
non-threatening so someone who's coming
in these spaces who might
if you just spoke at them say privilege
you're infiltrating
but to hear it poetically they might sit
back and like
okay let me receive this because one is
beautiful to listen to but it's also
it's not it's it's something that
they're going to turn on and think on
later because it stays with you because
it moves in rhyme and verse and we hold
on to that more
yeah does that make sense like bypassing
the gatekeeper is something that's been
talked about in art and music
really performance for a while yeah
that's a that's a really good way to put
it and
if you can do these different ways of uh
synthesizing storytelling art that
is awakening
it's uh transformative for our
collective and so
i really like the example in dc because
actually we're experiencing this
in the bay area in oakland a lot right
now um
we're experiencing the across the world
in different
areas of just urbanization we in even
somewhere like oaxaca city
right you know you wouldn't have ever
thought that that there would be
an indigenous that live right outside
the city that have
had urbanization happening to them and
and so this is happening
in so many different places what what do
we do about
trying to retain culture and tradition
we've just seen this big power law
happening with language
languages are becoming like dead
economic languages nobody wants to speak
them anymore you're just learning
english or mandarin uh and that's you
know this
this is like what what what do we do
about retaining
the culture that we
it's it's so unfortunate at times that
yes we want to build
the singularity and artificial general
intelligence so we need all the
engineers moving to
san francisco right but you know you but
then you have
the these beautiful artists that
have that aren't able to pay three grand
a month
right in rent um and so there's got to
be a new
way of seeing what the value is that
actually philosophy morality uh
ethics um spirituality that if we don't
embed those things
in uh engineering and design
and the general intelligence and all
these things that we're trying to build
that we're gonna have more suffering by
accident
right we do that yeah speaking of
collective yeah not just saying oh
because now it's stem only right stem
and humanity's even becoming like
obsolete it's seeing that they all work
together right
like biz we need business we need
farmers
we need artists we need all of it right
but in terms of what do we do to
preserve
i mean i think this is one thing i do
like about anthropology especially as
especially linguistic anthropology there
are a lot of movements that are
preserving language there are a lot of
revitalization movements
that are trying to save
endangered languages or what could be
seen
as those that are dying out
and some of that can be problematic
depending on who's revitalizing because
someone might say well what version of
the language gets
you know privileged as the real language
that was dying out but
but still there are these movements in
place where people are trying
and aware and i think a lot of
anthropologists come from that trying to
preserve
text like from native americans a lot of
what i've learned about linguistic
anthropology where people were trying to
say
we don't want to lose this even it was
done a lot
outside of the community though not from
the people themselves
but what i like is a lot of people from
within the communities
and that's what i'm trying to do is
trying to highlight
spoken word poetry so that it is brought
into academic consciousness so that it
can
be celebrated not just in public spaces
but in academic spaces
so i think a lot of scholars are finding
you know the arts and the languages that
they have connections to and doing work
that will hopefully
preserve it in other words you know ways
whether that's for
um by writing about it in journals in my
case i would love to do an ethnographic
film
to kind of even show it you know from
you know to a late audience and not just
do it
for academic spaces yes but
part of it is being okay
or to know that my language is valuable
right that it is worth preserving
and it's i didn't even know first off
that i spoke this thing called
african-american language but i was very
much
taught as the middle class blacks
female get rid of it don't talk like
that that's not going to get you
anywhere
right you need to sound educated it
wasn't until i entered in classrooms
that gave me
a term that there's this thing called
african american english
at the time and by giving it a name it
gave it power
it made it real right but then to see
people who were studying this and
calling it this has a structure this has
value you know by saying that out loud
it empowered me to own it first we can't
preserve it if we don't own it right we
can't preserve it if we don't believe
it's valuable
so i think first by defining it and
giving people space to
then say okay this deserves study and
then letting people
um operate in that because a lot of
there's a lot of languages that get
impeded
by power structures whether that's
governments whether that's
institutions and academics that say this
is invaluable because i don't speak that
or that looks like you're dumb or that
looks like you're
you know you don't belong here right i
think
redefining what is language for people
um and redefining and taking away things
that says this is bad and this is good
or this is right and this is wrong
redefining what standardization is like
okay american standard english is just
one variety not
the variety how we talk about it will
change how things get preserved as well
so a lot of it's just education and then
a lot of it is patronizing i mean one of
the things about
spoken word arts or arts in general in
order to preserve it is we have to go
out and seek it out
right vote with your dollars support
artists
support their movements get involved i
might not be a spoken word artist but i
can be an enthusiast
and i can learn about it and i can give
back by whether through my scholarship
or just going to spoken word everywhere
every city i go that's what i used to do
let me find the spoken word cafes let me
find that you know
so it's also patronizing these returning
the arts
i mean not patronizing patroning the
arts yeah you know
giving your dollars to things you
believe and giving your time
to things because it's not just dollars
we don't we i'm not rich by any means
i'm
a phd student but i gave my time
i gave my dedication to wanting to learn
about this
and they were very much like wow you
really want to do a dissertation on this
yes because it has value
yeah yeah it seems as though there's
pretty much an infinite amount of
permutations that exist for ways to
leverage arts
to awaken people to
culture that is that can be preserved we
can leverage art to preserve
culture and it can be patroned by
people that both want to go and attend
with their time and experience
and also just financially monetarily
there's
there's a big issue that we have
happening right now where
it's as though these top 1500
billionaires on the planet are choosing
again whether it's consciously or
unconsciously they're
choosing to purchase additional boats
planes
cars designer clothes you name it and
they're not choosing to support the 50
of the population that still makes less
than 2.50
a day which is our cost of a cup of
coffee right so
there is a big consciousness shift that
needs to happen
from that top perspective about the use
of
arts and the way that arts can actually
do things that eventually
we'll all want which is to know how we
even got here in the first place
so use the arts to preserve things that
give us a better understanding of
cultural evolution how we actually got
here
and then have it and then have it
recorded you know have it recorded have
it accessible documented
yeah but you know and this is what i
love about language language has power
not you know and obviously i've seen
that by watching spoken word artists but
by giving things a label we
give it we say it exists right like
people always say why do we have to come
up with this word
called introduction i mean uh
intersectionality or why do we have to
come up with this word toxic masculinity
because if i can name it then i can
identify it i can see it i can figure
out how i feel about it i can position
myself closer or
away from that right how we define what
is even
art right is necessary because a lot of
people think of arts
it's ballet it's sculpting it's these
high
art right and then these folk arts
get kind of other and outside it
and if we also because there's so many
people that might still ask me well what
is bookwork they don't know about it
right so part of it is one redefining
what is art
um what gets value will again get a name
but then talking about it um sharing it
with others
right exposing it right because a lot of
what i've learned about in black culture
is
certain so things haven't existed long
before i started studying them but i
just wasn't hearing about it histories
weren't being passed down
that preserved it because people would
just say oh well you know
this is just what i know it's not a
value it's not of use i don't need to
talk about this anymore
and so we would be losing in my history
for instance in my family certain
stories or
oral histories that i'm like what i have
a father that
did this i have a you know a relative
that did that
we don't talk about it you know and by
not talking about it by not sharing and
passing down even the stories or
traditions
or calling it art we don't give it space
to be preserved
this is the other big challenge of our
times is
the economic machinery is just choking
people and it's making it so that
i can't even afford time
on love on friends
on passions on nature
passing down tradition traditions sleep
has taken the biggest toll
which directly affects our physiology
and our moment-to-moment health so we're
literally deteriorating when we sleep
four or six hours instead of like
you're talking to a grad student all of
these it's
choking us it's choking us people can't
the something that's so deeply important
is
being able to fall in love to experience
deep profound love to have a so a robust
social network with five or ten
really good friends cooking meals
growing food experiencing all these
things has taken a huge back seat to the
fact that i gotta run at work all day
long
if you're in survival mode there's not
time for this stuff
right if you're literally i mean and i'm
speaking literally from a grad
experience if i got to choose between
doing laundry and feeding myself
and doing this paper and i think that's
where we are there is not enough time to
enjoy life to build community
if you can't build community how can i
see myself in another person's
experience
if i can't talk to someone how do i pass
down to pass down these traditions
if i don't have time to if i'm working
10 jobs how do i have time to go
and see this great artistic space right
i mean what do you do with that when
you're in hustle mode all the time
and that's something i'm learning too
that was reflected in a spoken word
culture
a lot of them had to actively work to
preserve these spaces and weren't
sleeping these were artists that were
just saying you know i'm gonna take away
from sleep because i find this art in
this life and this poet thing so
important not only because it's feeding
me
but because like literally feeding me in
terms of like putting money in my pocket
but it's feeding my community
emotionally healing trauma right so
a lot of the artists they were going off
of four hours of sleep
to give back to the art but is that
helping i don't know
you know you got to make you're robbing
peter to pay paul in a sense
to figure out what is a value to
preserve myself
right or to be economically viable or to
be community centered
is choices and this redesign
of our global social fabric is
a main future focus yet in order to do
so
with the greatest amount of awareness we
need to start with the first principle
of the deepest amount of the one the
interconnectedness there is no
separation
the unity with all of the other species
on this planet
the interconnectedness of our ecological
systems that sustain us if a child is
taught all of that upon birth
and they're able to experientially know
it and share it in project-based
learning around solving the sustainable
development goals during their uh
educational process learning social
emotional intelligences
if all of that happens that new future
that new social fabric
has the breathing space for all of these
great things that we've been talking
about
right but otherwise right now at times
it just
feels like there is just a couple of
people in the planet
that are just siphoning off all of these
new emerging market
fruits of all these new emerging
technologies that are coming and
people are stuck we're just stuck median
mail income in the u.s
flatlining gdp skyrocketing where is all
the money going mm-hmm
we know where it's going right it's
going to the top one percent
we know it's not it's not aware anymore
so we know
and next is uh if you're not willing
to pay a half a percent tax on all wall
street
transactions to try and fund
these types of educational first
principled ideas
then you are not enlightened whatsoever
and you have
no place at all in the discourse
period but if your systems say
capitalism right which says competition
is good and i have the
right to go out and earn as much as i
can get
right to be as successful as i can get
based on my own merit
and i got here by my own doing and i
have the right to collect as much wealth
as i want there is no we embedded in
that kind of structure in and of itself
right so then to say one percent can you
please
pass down some and say no to opportunity
say no to wealth
and you know for the greater good that's
not built into the structure that
allowed them to get that wealth right
and you know community have you heard of
inclusive stakeholding
no it's uh just like how uh
you're you know you're like back in the
tribal days
or even today your mom will not
tell you something to try and like get
money from you
your mom and dad are telling you things
because they care about you
right and just like your tribe members
would it's inclusive fitness would tell
you stuff
don't go over there you know eat this
etc because they cared about you and the
rest of tribe members
now you have people that tell you things
to earn money from you right and it's a
big food
it's transactional transactional
relationships and so an inclusive
stakeholding
solves that by doing things like
when you when you do something like off
when you have a physician the physician
has a stake in the actual patient that
is visiting them the teacher has a stake
in the student
right right right these types of things
or you can even go to the
company level and say that okay fine
well a company like
uber you find yourself in downtown san
francisco you
have employees and shareholder and
shareholders and investors
these are the people that are funding
most of it yes go ahead and take the
shares that you would like at the same
time allocate
shares to the drivers that are driving
to create your wealth allocate shares to
the customers that are buying the fares
that are then also creating your wealth
and the community of san francisco that
you have your headquarters in
these are really important aspects to
the design
of the new social contract that make it
so that everyone takes the fruits
right and not just a select few right
but again you have to be socialized into
that thinking
right from very early on community is
we throw that word around but what does
that really mean right
if if your community are the people who
just look like you
or the people who's in the one top
percent or the people you believe that
got where they
you know they should get because they
deserved it
right if that's your community it's
limited to that but if your community is
again i say i see myself as a global
citizen my
but i also see myself as part of the
african-american community the academic
community it's also
being recognized i'm part of multiple
communities at the same time
right um and i'm not limited to
one and that does not mean that i can
only move in this space
but i see myself in these
different perspectives as part of these
different groups
but i've been socialized by people
before me by my mentors by
my family to see myself that way i
have friends that grew up right down the
street from me that don't see themselves
they just see themselves in
atlanta community or the black community
or
you know whatever job they're in and i'm
sure the same way
everyone has to kind of be told yes
there's this local thing there's this
family thing but then there's this
national thing there's this global thing
there's this ecological thing
yeah the scales and that's actually what
i bring in my research because i'm like
there's so many levels to this
yeah but if you can't see those levels
it's connected then you do move in this
like one dimensional
yes yes yes yes so these are the
world view augmentations to be able to
actually
see those different scales and to truly
also experientially know the truth of
those scales that you don't just go
and get something from a store for a
sheet of paper
and then just toss it later and then
just that all
no these things are sourced from
somewhere manufactured somewhere
then shipped across oceans and they land
in the stores and you
spend time making money and then it just
goes into landfill you know this
is a very complicated intricate process
that if you've never actually went to
the extent of
trying to understand you will
continuously
immerse yourself in ignorance and and i
will i will until the day i die
be chipping away at the boulder of
ignorance that is attached to my ankle
and i and i will keep going and i will
keep learning and i will keep trying to
learn the most important things
that i think can build that future world
that i want to live
in and it to have that style of passion
in instilled whatever works for people
on their climb up the mountain it's not
a one-size-fits-all thing
whatever way works for you to climb up
the mountain towards your gifts
towards the oneness right do it
but go and know that that is one of
these first principles and that you
can't
you can't just plop a child onto the
monopoly board of the economic machinery
right right but again it's
it's how we talk about things
at a very basic level i mean when you
can't have conversations around dinner
table which doesn't even happen right
but
you know i look at and i try to give
people a break
because i understand i heard this from
i can't remember who it was that
everyone wakes up in their own time
right like you know it's easy to look at
someone that says
oh you're not part of this greater
consciousness at one point i wasn't
either
right someone had to wake me up right i
don't know who it was maybe it was a
collective that did it or
multiple interactions that did it but
along the way as i woke up
i can't look back at someone and say oh
you just not woke i wasn't either we all
wake up at different times right
but it's being aware that if i
now that i am woke how can i talk to
other people in ways with compassion
with kindness you know with
understanding of that
they're on their own trajectory that
will maybe just be a seed
you know just plan to see the water that
and i look at
and i'm it's just a random example like
you were just talking about
seeing source material as being part of
this bigger structure
i remember looking at a tv show where
these kids um
they were people were judging oh they
just don't eat healthy they just don't
eat healthy and just judging them
they had no idea ketchup came from a
tomato
it was so fascinating i can't remember
it was the show
i think his name was jamie oliver was
trying to do in the states to
revolutionize how
cafeteria gets uh cafeteria food gets
talked about and dealt with in
low-income spaces it's very easy to say
you're just not eating healthy and just
write people off as being ignorant
right but if kids had never known here's
a tomato
and here's ketchup here's chicken
nuggets that comes from chicken
here is fries that come from a potato
right they had no idea because no one
had introduced them to that
right but they were just moving about in
the world just saying
i eat chicken nuggets i eat fries and i
eat ketchup and that's all i know but
people were judging them as being
ignorant
right but when jamie came in and
introduced them and gave them a picture
of
no this comes from this yes and this is
farmed from farmers
yes and this was planted in this way and
this is going to feed this economy
right these kids were excited about it
they did not want to know
right it wasn't like they were like i
don't want to know i'm going to walk
around with blinders someone had to
introduce them to that in a very
non-threatening way
without judgment we also can't just be
talking to people and saying you should
give up power
you should do this because you you know
you're horrible there has to be a way to
have these conversations
in a place that yes is critical but that
allows people to wake up in their
own time yeah yeah yeah that's great
tiffany thank you so much for that that
was so nice
i really appreciate it and um and that's
a really good example of just um
a way to just introduce that uh
compassionate style of education
and uh yeah that's a that's really good
because academy can be very judgmental
and and elitist and i don't want to be
that
yeah so i try to think about it from a
place of compassion
i have a final question okay
what do you think is most beautiful
oh my gosh that is so
difficult um
[Music]
i think and this is it sounds so loaded
but i was talking about it
with a friend today who's actually here
we talked a lot about this and i think
we're kind of talking about it now
empathy right um
not just sympathy and being able to look
down at someone say oh poor you
but to be able to look at someone's
experience as different as it is and to
find
something of connection that then makes
it
relevant to you i might not have
literally walked in your shoes like i
might not have not grown up in this
context that you existed but i
appreciate family i
appreciate i have struggled before
therefore i can respect that your
struggle wow looks different
it still makes sense to me right and
still
understand that i want you to achieve
and to grow and to dream and to
write like to look at someone that you
might not have absolutely nothing in
common with
but to work to find commonality in some
way
if nothing else in just being in the
we're in the human experience of trying
i feel like everyone's doing the best
they can if nothing else
i think that's beautiful to give people
that
kindness in this world of unkindness
i hope that's not sappy but as someone
who has struggled
a lot as a black adamic as a black
female
as a black scholar as the first
generation scholar in my family
what has made me continue to do this is
those
people who i've empathized with me and
helped me along the way
that little bit of extra love and
empathy
butterfly effects out in the
actualization of the gifts
and then i will do that again for
someone else
[Music]
thanks thanks for coming on thank you
for inviting me this is fun
i'm glad you had fun thanks for all your
great work really appreciate it thank
you
thank you thanks everyone for tuning in
we really appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts
in the comments below on the episode let
us know what you're thinking
check out all of tiffany's links in the
bio below as well
you can also find the american
anthropological association links in the
bible support them as well
you can find all of our show links as
well in the bio you can support the
artist the entrepreneurs the spiritual
leaders the organizations in your
communities and around the world that
you believe in support them and help
them grow
patron the arts please patreon arts
you can find all of our links to patreon
cryptocurrency paypal
design merchant get paid all those links
in the bio below
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in build the next world we'll see you
soon
that's awesome thank you
thank you
[Music]
you